luglio
Bartolomeo sala Ambasciatore per la
famiglia Estense presso la Corte dei
Cosimo dei medici scriveva a Ercole
primodeste il caldo che pativano
grandissimo a Palazzo Vecchio è un caldo
insopportabile Maggiore assai che a
Ferrara
al di là di capire che già il nostro
clima atroce di Ferrara era noto nel
Cinquecento questo scambio ci deve far
pensare ci deve far pensare che il
problema del caldo eccessivo per dirlo
in termini contemporanei
dell’innalzamento delle temperature non
è un tema recente Anzi
Guardate queste testate giornalistiche
titolavano sul cambiamento climatico già
nel 1912 poi negli anni 50 poi negli
anni 80
Il problema è quello che l'uomo ha fatto
da allora A oggi
oggi che stiamo vivendo quello con lo
studioso Moreno definisce il tempo della
policrisi
stiamo vivendo una pluralità di crisi
che arrivano da più ambiti da fronti
diversi Non è più la nostra una crisi
tematizzata come avveniva in passato ma
è sfaccettata ed è questo che ci
spaventa perché ci fa sentire inadeguati
non possiamo più parlare di crisi
ambientale senza aggiungerci la crisi
sanitaria la crisi economica la crisi
sociale che ne è derivata
però Sappiamo anche che l'uomo è quello
che è grazie alle crisi che ha dovuto
superare che gli hanno permesso di
evolvere
Il mio compito Quindi come ricercatrice
è quello di studiare metodi di
costruzione sostenibile per ripristinare
una sana relazione tra l'uomo e
l'ambiente in cui vive Diciamo che sto
cercando di dare il mio piccolo
contributo al superamento della crisi e
tra le tante strade possibili quella che
ho scelto è di intervenire sul
patrimonio storico
potrei dire di voler unire un concetto
di innovazione un'idea di futuro al
substrato culturale
perché i valori e i ricordi insieme
all'inedito ci permettono di ricostruire
la nostra identità di risanare la nostra
società in crisi
Però allora il problema Perché parlare
di edilizia storica e sostenibilità
guardate questa inedita immagine di
Venezia con la laguna completamente
ghiacciata
E pensate che all'interno della metà del
sei Settecento in questo caso a fronte
di problemi di raffreddamento eccessivo
se iniziato a parlare di cambiamento
climatico come noi oggi lo intendiamo
i temi di cui parliamo non sono attuali
come crediamo hanno radici molto
profonde ciò che è cambiato sono gli
strumenti con i quali Possiamo e
dobbiamo studiarli
parlando con molti di voi Probabilmente
se vi chiedessi di descrivermi un
edificio Green poco energivoro la
maggioranza mi farebbe l'identikit di un
edificio di nuova costruzione
fotovoltaico domotico addirittura magari
con le pale eoliche sul tetto
avreste sicuramente ragione ma non è
solo questo
la sostenibilità non passa solo
attraverso la costruzione di edifici
nuovi super efficienti
gli edifici esistenti sono già stati
costruiti è già stato consumato suolo ed
energia per la loro realizzazione
riqualificare significa quindi Non
disperdere questa risorse ma anzi
rimetterle nel ciclo di vita
dell'edificio Diciamo che è un po' come
quando ricicliamo la carta la plastica e
il vetro dovremo considerare
l'opportunità di dare una nuova vita
anche al nostro patrimonio storico
e in Italia abbiamo più di 22.000 centri
storici e quasi 50.000 beni
architettonici vincolati
guardando le opere del passato risulta
chiaro come l'uomo abbia più o meno
consapevolmente costruito sin dalle
origini pensando la propria casa come
uno spazio per controllare il clima
verso nord gli edifici debbano essere
ben chiusi senza apertura al contrario
sotto l'impieto del sole o del calore
prima e le costruzioni devono essere
aperte e rivolte a settentrione
Vitruvio nel suo dearchitettura 15
avanti Cristo teorizza una prassi ormai
consolidata cioè quella di progettare
gli edifici a partire dal corretto
orientamento dei fronti
i nostri predecessori erano bravi erano
bravi a costruire dei muri Tanto grossi
da rallentare l'ingresso del calore
Credo che quasi tutti avremo provato
refrigerio entrando in una chiesa antica
no d'estate
costruivano con quelli che noi oggi
chiamiamo i materiali a km 0
le pareti erano isolate grazie agli
arazzi alle boiserie in legno i letti a
baldacchino servivano a ripararsi
d'inverno dagli spifferi gelidi delle
lunghe notti
Poi è chiaro quando il duca o
addirittura il papa incaricavano un
architetto della costruzione del proprio
Palazzo
volevano rappresentare la propria
importanza attraverso la sfarzosità
della Dimora quindi una sa con una
quantità enorme di risorse sono state
destinate alla realizzazione di questi
edifici Ma non solo per gli affreschi
dei cori dei saloni di rappresentanza in
taluni casi si sono costruite realizzate
dei sistemi di controllo ambientale
tanto sofisticati da essere paragonabile
dei veri e propri impianti di
condizionamento pre-industriale
i romani per esempio parliamo di
riscaldamento
primo secolo avanti Cristo nell'età
Imperiale imparano dai cugini greci per
poi migliorarlo il sistema per scaldare
l'acqua delle Terme da lì a poco lo
stesso sistema viene impiegato per
scaldare d'inverno le domus dei più
ambienti e la Domus Aurea per esempio il
sistema è semplice Focolare scaldava
l'aria che arrivava alle stanze
attraverso dei cavedi a pavimento a
parete
d'estate invece per il caldo eccessivo
Beh Prima abbiamo visto Bartolomeo sala
che parlava del caldo opprimente di
Palazzo Vecchio la famiglia medici
Quindi cosa faceva sudava forse un po'
Però in realtà si spostava si spostava
nelle residenze estive di Palazzo Pitti
dove era stato insegnato un sistema
fantastico per stare al fresco
è strano Vi chiedo invece che guardare i
meravigliosi affreschi di Palazzo Pitti
di guardare il pavimento in particolare
quella griglia bianca che permetteva di
mettere in collegamento i Vani ipogei
con i saloni e portare quindi l'aria
fresca naturalmente presente nelle
cantine negli spazi di vita in questo
modo Ovviamente li raffrescava si stava
meglio alle volte nelle cantine veniva
aggiunto una vasca d'acqua piovana una
ghiacciaia per enfatizzare questo
effetto alcune simulazioni dimostrano
che si raggiungessero i 26-28 gradi che
non mi sembrano male Considerando che è
un sistema totalmente passivo E siamo
nel 500
dovete poi immaginare il tutto studiato
pensato insieme alla distribuzione
planimetrica dell'edificio per esempio
le finestre erano opportunamente aperte
su fronti opposti le nostre nonne ci
insegnano che la casa sana e quella con
la ventilazione incrociata queste
finestre hanno poi aperte si
affacciavano sui Giardini i cortili I
Chiostri i portici questo innescava un
effetto camino che era in grado di
attirare l'acqua dalle l'aria Scusate
dalle cantine e innescare la
ventilazione naturale
Ecco Ora pensiamo al tessuto storico
delle nostre città
quanti di questi spazi come Chiostri
Portici cortili ci sono che non vengono
opportunamente sfruttati
questo per esempio il nostro palazzo
Costabile detto di Ludovico il Moro dove
Il Chiostro principale è meraviglioso è
in collegamento con altri due loggiati e
gli spazi ipogei
qui la ventilazione naturale è
fantastica e lo si vede anche dalla
posizione della sedia dello staff che
cerca empiricamente il fresco
Ecco dopo qualche anno dalla loro
realizzazione molti se non tutti questi
sistemi di controllo ambientale e la
funzione regolatrice degli spazi aperti
è stata abbandonata
perché ignorata o peggio perché non se
ne conosceva la funzione
Al di là degli esempi più eclatanti
riconoscere la presenza di questi
sistemi ci permette di conoscere il
comportamento energetico dell'edificio
prima di intervenire prima magari di
aggiungere isolante termico alle
facciate penso al bonus 110 con tutti i
problemi di compatibilità Credetemi che
questo implica
quindi dobbiamo imparare a conoscere
questi sistemi per comprenderli e
riattivarli potrei dire riabilitarli
come
per esempio sfruttando i sistemi le
tecnologie digitali d'avanguardia di cui
noi oggi disponiamo in un dialogo attivo
tra l'edificio e l'uomo invece che
aggiungere nuovo materiale all'involucro
facciamo in modo che questo lavori nel
migliore dei modi per esempio un sistema
di sensoristica collegato alla rete
permetterebbe di rilevare costantemente
le condizioni ambientali nell'edificio
E a seconda di quello che viene rilevato
il sistema può automaticamente cambiare
alcune configurazioni nel fabbricato per
esempio si possono aprire o chiudere le
porte o le finestre nel momento più
opportuno per innescare quella
ventilazione naturale che vedevamo prima
per esempio spegnendo l'impianto
Pensate cosa hanno fatto i nostri
predecessori senza i computer e cosa
possiamo fare noi oggi che abbiamo nella
Nanotecnologia la sensoristica i
software
l'edificio può diventare interattivo
senza consumare risorse ma soprattutto
senza stravolgerne i connotati storici
Ovviamente questo è importante per chi
deve intervenire nella riqualificazione
di questi fabbricati ma non crediate che
sia meno importante perché
quotidianamente vive o lavora in un
edificio storico il buon funzionamento
di un fabbricato Infatti parte proprio
dalla gestione che se ne fa
il tempo di oggi vede tremare i tre
cardini della sostenibilità una crisi
economica una crisi ambientale e una
crisi sociale una crisi dei valori
leggere in quest'ottica il nostro
patrimonio storico può rappresentare un
primo passo per il superamento di questa
situazione e le ragioni sono
innumerevoli Innanzitutto invece che
leggere come un atto di violenza un
intervento di riqualificazione
energetica di un edificio storico
Vediamola così condizioni ambientali più
stabili portano minori fenomeni di
degrado delle opere dei decori che
vengono contenuti nell'edificio Che
significa una migliore conservazione del
bene e dei valori testimoniali di cui è
portatore in cui noi tutti la società si
identifica
Poi è chiaro che innalzare i livelli di
comfort degli utenti negli edifici
significa maggiore attrattività del bene
stesso che detto In altre parole
significa se nell'edificio sto bene i
visitatori sono richiamati e questo può
essere una idea di per la riattivazione
di un motore economico per esempio
basato sul turismo sostenibile
in ultimo ma non ultimo è che il un
intervento sul patrimonio pubblico se
fatto bene può
fungere da effetto traino l'effetto Eco
sulla collettività
facendo in modo che venga attivato una
serie di interventi sul patrimonio
privato che ha Ovviamente un impatto
molto maggiore sulle nostre città
Quindi quello che tutti noi oggi
possiamo fare è di non dimenticare per
tramandare a chi verrà il concetto
ancestrale di sostenibilità
per reinterpretare prima ancora che
inventare Grazie
[Applauso]